if heard Donald Trump described you as a
stupid guy you should be jailed Mike
Pompeo he's called you a traitor then
you have Nancy Pelosi a Democrat saying
you chose profits over patriotism do you
understand why people believe that by
trying to sell your book you're
potentially selling out your own country
well I don't I don't think that way at
all I think the Democrats are upset that
their political malpractice on
impeachment brought them to failure and
so of course they're looking for others
to blame but it's the way they approach
the impeachment process I think that
preordained the outcome that Donald
Trump is upset with me doesn't surprise
me at all his reactions frankly have
been childish and degrading to the
presidency one of the most damning
aspects of your book is that you
basically confirmed that there was a
quid pro quo with Ukraine that's
ultimately what got the president
impeached and yet you stayed quiet you
didn't testify in the impeachment
inquiry critics say that that means
you're complicit and cowardly no I
reject that completely look the House
Democrats took the impeachment process
right off a cliff and halfway down they
looked up and said hey come and join us
and I was not about to do that you paint
a picture of him as almost in or of
strong men you know desperate for
meetings with Kim jong-un and Vladimir
Putin were they playing him for a fool I
think they were I think they could see
through him I don't think they were
overt about it but I I think they knew
exactly who the mark was he would say
that the relationship with those men he
was able to foster in a way no other
leader before him did right well let's
take Kim jong-un he got nothing for it
after two years of effort in fact in
just the past few weeks the North
Koreans have literally blown up the
liaison offices they constructed to have
talks with the South Koreans the whole
thing came to nothing but a series of
photo opportunities which with all due
respect I think was entirely predict
what really strikes me reading this book
is all of those if you like cosmetic
moments when we saw Donald Trump shaking
their hands of world leaders and there
was great fanfare and you were a part of
that you were at those moments embracing
them publicly privately it seems that
you were very worried
how can readers trust you when it's such
a shift one thing I've learned in years
of experience in the Reagan
administration both Bush presidencies is
you're not going to have your point of
view prevail all the time in fact
probably most of the time it won't
prevail but you keep at it because you
hope that you're making a contribution
and you continue to do it and you don't
speak out publicly while you're in the
administration you shouldn't try to
undercut the president until you get to
the point where as a matter of your own
personal judgment you just can't do it
anymore that you think things are so off
track that the only honorable thing to
do is resign and that's what I did was
reelected often put above national
security in my judgment yes front
doesn't really have a philosophy or a
grand strategy or even policies that he
follows it's all about Donald Trump and
it it follows from that in in many
respects he has a very short attention
span not when it comes to his reelection
his attention span there is infinite
what do you think is his worst crime
when it comes to foreign policy look I
think ignorance is the worst crime I
just don't think that saying that I
don't need more facts I can I can sit
down as he has said I can sit down with
the ayatollah khamenei will hammer out a
nuclear deal in one day it's just not
true so when I think of the prospect of
him on the other side of the table from
Vladimir Putin negotiating a strategic
arms treaty I'm very worried for the
United States you describe Donald Trump
as stunningly uninformed in the
during one trip he appeared unaware that
Britain was a nuclear power is he really
that clueless I can tell you in that
meeting which was at checkers hosted by
Prime Minister May when the president
made that comment the stiff British
upper lips didn't quiver but their eyes
got wide as saucers and I was sitting
there thinking to myself what do we say
next and I think Prime Minister made
changes the subject fairly quickly well
let's talk about to resume and Donald
Trump's relationship with her you say
that he didn't like her that he felt the
feeling was mutual can you elaborate a
bit on that well I think they come from
obviously very different backgrounds
have very different approaches to
politics my own opinion and I can't
improve this I think he has trouble with
women leaders I think he had trouble
with Chancellor Merkel and Germany these
are not substantive disagreements these
are personality issues but because of
the way Trump looks at relations with
other leaders he cannot he has enormous
difficulty distinguishing between the
personal relationship he has with the
leader of another country and the
fundamental u.s. relationship with the
other country as a whole do you think
he's sexist you know I don't know what
the issue is but but time and again we
seem to run into that difficulty don't
get me wrong he had bad relationships
with plenty of male leaders too he says
he's a stable genius how would you
describe them well let me let me ask you
this do you know of anybody else in your
personal acquaintance who would say that
about themselves
neither do I so that's my answer that
tells you a lot about what you need to
know is there any one in that White
House Donald Trump will listen to you
who's the most important person in there
right now next to him I think without
question its Jared Kushner and I think
this is this is another vulnerability I
think you know I'm not I don't and don't
insist as a matter of morality on
anti-nepotism rules but I think there's
a common-sense element to that that has
nothing to do
prohibiting favoritism to your family
it's you react the family people
differently than you react to others and
the white house is not a family business
it's not a small enterprise the u.s. is
currently gripped by coronavirus racial
division is this a country in decline no
I don't think so at all but I do think
the Trump leadership during these two
crises has made things worse much of our
failure to respond effectively can be
laid at Donald Trump's feet Donald Trump
didn't want to hear it he didn't want to
hear bad news about his buddy he's in
pink
didn't want to hear the truth about
China covering up the extent of the
threat of the coronavirus most important
of all he didn't want to hear about
potential bad economic news for the
United States from a widespread pandemic
which would endanger his ticket to
re-election you say you won't vote for
Donald Trump or Joe Biden but you must
be more concerned about the prospect of
one of those men becoming president than
the other look the the the choices and
is an unacceptable one to me and that's
why I'm going to write in a conservative
Republican it's a protest vote I
understand that I also understand I live
in Maryland which will go for Joe Biden
no matter how John Bolton votes other
people on the Republican Party side have
said they will vote for Biden I respect
that choice but it's not mine do you
think he's dangerous look I think his
inability or unwillingness to learn what
a an American president needs to know
about strategic weapons about the threat
of proliferation of biological chemical
and nuclear weapons about the nature of
the international system that we live in
his penchant for making gut-level
decisions in the morning and then
changing them in the afternoon yes I
think all of these things are dangerous
and I recount several instances
including a conversation I had with the
former chief of staff John Kelly where
we talked about our fear of what would
happen in a crisis and
I think the corona virus pandemic is is
a kind of crisis where what we feared
has come true and I fear more than an
even more serious crisis it could be
worse